hello my name is Mohammed or ami I'll be
talking about demystifying you know
quantum theory using computation say
hello everyone my name is Mohammad or
Rami I'm with the world from documen the
major system I'm also a lecturer at the
Cal State LA teaching chemistry quantum
chemistry thermodynamic upper level and
lower level courses today I'll be
talking about using computational essays
to demystify quantum mechanics so
basically in our quantum theory is the
most successful physical theory that has
been developed so far however at the
foundation of quantum theory there are
lots of lots of open problems and the
most famous one is the measurement
problem quantum theory the most
successful theory developed by humankind
but it doesn't explain the measurement
process basically the measurement
process appears as a postulate in
quantum theory and since from the very
beginning you know the founding fathers
among them honest and shooting a Duke
boy they were not happy about that
however because of the Copenhagen school
for the larger ball I would say 50 years
feces they somehow ignore this
foundational problem but about 60 70s
you know works of David warm John Bell
you know feces to start thinking about
the foundational problems and what are
the approaches that we could tackle this
problem now we have a zoo of different
interpretations I would say at least you
know 50 popular interpretation of the
quantum theory however today I'm not
going to talk about different
interpretations I'm going to talk about
some alternative quantum theories so
basically we have different mathematical
models for the quantum theory they may
provide different predictions therefore
we could test them in the experiment we
would either falsify those theories or
we would falsify the quantum mechanics
in particular I'll talk about two of
them the most popular ones one of them
is called bomb theory or pilot wave
theory or deployed bomb theory the other
one is called UPS models so let me start
with the bomb theory what is above
Theory basically now involved theory we
have a very important message from the
very beginning whenever you talk about
particles minute
particle has a well-defined trajectory
therefore write on a mathematical
equation describing that well-defined
trajectory therefore here we have a
deterministic motion of particles this
deterministic motion has two
mathematical equation so in this model
we have two mathematical equation one of
them is shorting equation the other one
is a different mathematical equation is
a new mathematical equation second we
know that at the quantum level we have
probabilities how we can explain those
probabilities the connection between
bohmian mechanic this new alternative
theory and probabilities this
description is very similar to the
connection of for example classical
mechanic and a statistical mechanic so
we go from a deterministic theory to a
probabilistic description following
Boltzmann approach now in order to
derive the probabilities I should talk
about the very important concept which
is called typicality so basically there
are possibilities for deviation from a
standard behavior from the usual
behavior but whenever we talk about
probabilities we are talking about
typical behavior we would say that most
particles they would behave like that
that's how we would do reasoning we
being a deterministic theory so the
fundamental concept to do a
probabilistic description within a
deterministic theory is typicality
an embalming mechanic it is based on
some physicists that would call it
postulate some physicists they can
explain it that let me call it postulate
that assumption is called quantum
equilibrium what is the quantum eclipta
me tells you that for an ensemble of
identical particles all of them having
the same function the empirical
distribution is approximately equal to
the modulus square of the wave function
so this is a very important assumption
in Bamiyan mechanic but again let me go
back to the original idea in brief so
mathematical equation and one
probabilistic reasoning going from a
deterministic theory to a probabilistic
description now let me show you the
equations of motion so the second
equation of motion is shown in equation
we all know the Schrodinger equation the
first one is the new equation in Bamiyan
the cat is represented trajectory of
particle depending on wave function you
see we have a very strange mathematical
formula here imaginary of blood bunch of
other terms so this is the new equation
in Bamiyan mechanic as you can see the
trajectory of particles depends on the
wave function that's why you know it is
called guiding wave or pilot wave so two
mathematical equation one for trajectory
one for the shooting equation now let's
see how wall from can help us with
understanding of Bamiyan economy so you
know the biggest challenge if you open
any text book about bohmian mechanics
you will see only one famous example
free evolution a Gaussian evolving in
free space and time why because that's
the one with analytical solution and for
some reason I don't know why physicists
or those who wrote those books they are
not interested in doing numerical
calculation you know why because then
you have to go through all these steps
telling your students how we should do
the numerical calculation within for
example shoulding equation but with the
Wolfram language you can easily do that
so for example as I saw with the
Gaussian and then let us consider a
potential like this so we have a
potential barrier and let us consider a
very strange condition when the initial
kinetic energy is less than the height
barrier basically according to the
classical mechanics a particle can not
go through this potential barrier so the
famous
quantum tunneling and what we do here is
a very simple let me just show you the
final answer numerical evaluation of the
wave function so we start with this wave
function actually it's the modulus
squared of the wave function so we here
we have the probability distribution and
then when it reaches the height barriers
as you can see a reflection happens and
then look at this part a tiny portion of
let me just magnify that a tiny portion
of the wave function can passes through
the height barrier this is a completely
non classical feature and I obtain this
result using numerical simulation using
built in function of Mathematica you
know this is a very simple example but
you cannot find it in any textbook
because you cannot explain numerical
simulation in a textbook if you'll take
like one chapter of describing you have
to discretize the space and time and use
this approximation use this method to
get this one and then that's how you can
simulate the wave function and that's
the result but you know within like a
few lines we can see the result and
while the tunneling is a very
interesting phenomena because look at
this part here we have quantum tunneling
but look at the other side I guess that
looks familiar it's like an interference
pattern actually it is an interference
between one side of the wave function
and be reflected side so within one
example we have two quantum mysteries
let's call them quantum mysteries
tunneling and interference together so
it's an ideal example for the students
who are interested in quantum foundation
you can tell them look it's a quantum
tunneling but instead of a simple
tunneling we have Intel friends look at
the right side let me show you a nice
interference pattern and you see we have
an interference pattern and on the other
side we have quantum tunneling so both
phenomenons together why we can study
these two phenomenons together because
I'm using numerical simulation with
Wolfram
immediately I can find for me interject
toys again you know it's a new I'm not
going through the detail is a numerical
you know solution of a differential
equation
and that's the Bamiyan trajectories as
you can see you know the gray area is
the area that the wave function is
nonzero the the other area this area is
where we have our potential barrier as
you can see most particles reflection
and there are a few possibilities
particles they can go through the wave
function the exact they can go through
the high barrier and let me show you the
correspondence with the modulus square
of the wave function the probability
density here as you can see I plotted
the density of the wave function in the
background and then quantum trajectories
and as you can see the quantum
trajectory follows the location where
the modulus the square of the wave
function probability has the maximum
values and also let me show you the non
classical features of Bamiyan theory
which is let me just show you the last
picture which is the quantum potential
the strange feature that we have in
Bamiyan mechanic which is responsible
for the non locality in bong and
mechanic as you can see we have some
flat regions and then we have some
valleys and those blue trajectories they
represent the Bamiyan trajectories as
you can see the Bamiyan trajectory the
particles they prefer the flat regions
and they avoid the valleys ok so we
obtain somehow a classical description
of you know particle behavior using an
alternative quantum theory and all the
parameters are like you know we could
manipulate them we could change the
potential barrier we could change the
initial mass you could do whatever we
want in less than 10 minutes five
minutes the student can see quantum
interference quantum tunneling
everything describing an alternative
quantum field any questions so far
that's one way of seeing that but you
know like you know it's like if you tell
me like you know can I also test it
experimentally I would say it's it's not
clear like you know if that
interpretation of those trajectories are
correct but we can say that you know
it's I didn't talk about like you know
let me talk about another concept is you
know some text with the colleague just
show you the equation here so you see
this is we have a velocity field and the
particles the trajectory is the
probability flux is basically following
that velocity field that's one way of
seeing you know those trajectories which
is some any other question again
remember that in Bamiyan in bohmian
mechanics the estranged feature the new
feature is the quantum potential that I
showed you so this is the quantum
potential for quantum tunneling and
remember that the particles they prefer
the flat regions they would like to
avoid the valleys somehow the quantum
potential is responsible for a strange
quantum force the particles they can
tunnel through the height barrier so
that's one alternative quantum theory so
basically you know in a standard
textbook in Bamiyan mechanic it would be
about I would say at least 150 pages
because they all talk about you know the
different interpretation they will talk
about like you know what is the bohmian
mechanics and they'll talk about log you
know how we could simulate these results
and then they'll go about you know
discretization a numerical calculation
at the end the students they would say
okay so tell me what is the physics
behind that that's the physics behind
this picture we have bunch of
trajectories it's reproduce the quantum
probabilities and
we have a new feature that new feature
is basically a new quantum potential and
remember that it's a hidden variable
theory and this quantum potential is
100% non-local it's a non-local
deterministic field now so the
observables here long now at the end of
the day what we observe are some
positions while you know you have a
detector plate here and you just observe
a bunch of points so the observables is
the final point you cannot observe that
trajectory because if you want to
observe that trajectory we know that you
would kill this quantum phenomena it
will be a different quantum phenomena
you would kill the car that's one way of
interpreting that in other words you
know I would like to use Bohr
terminology you cannot break down a
quantum phenomena into the simple steps
because if you do that it will be a new
quantum phenomena so for this quantum
phenomena remember that those that's why
it is called hidden variable theory the
positions are somehow hidden these are
the new variables that are hidden in it
standard quantum theory now let me talk
about another alternative quantum theory
which follows a totally different
approach so this approach it takes the
measurement much more seriously
so in Bamiyan mechanically would say
that look you know there is no collapse
of the wavefunction but here we take
that yes there is a collapse the
collapse is random let's find a
dynamical equation describing the
collapse so let's see what are the
fundamental assumptions in collapse
models so in collapse models we would
say okay I would like to describe the
collapse collapse using a dynamical
equation therefore I have to modify the
Schrodinger equation
that's one fundamental assumption the
second fundamental assumption is that
look you know at the end I know that the
probe
abilities they should follow the quantum
probabilities so we would start with
these two fundamental assumptions
describing the collapse through a
dynamical equation not an approximate
not a postulate so we are not
postulating the collapse of the
wavefunction we are describing the
collapse of the wavefunction but we say
that look remember that the collapse
should follows quantum probabilities and
using these two assumptions we would
modify quantum theory by guessing the
best possible alternatives so it's a
phenomenology called modification of
quantum theory why it is interesting
because you can go to the experiment and
you can test it you can say that okay if
it's right it tells me that at this mass
scale I should see this deviation from a
standard quantum theory either you would
falsify or you would verify these
theories now let me show you a simple
example
what is collapse donnelly the best
example that I found in the literature
is called gamblers ruin game so what is
this game I have like let's say ten
pennies you have 90 pennies and we start
you know throwing a coin head you will
give me one penny tail I'll give you one
penny and we keep playing until one of
us wins or lose the other one would lose
so it's a random process at the
beginning you have let's say I have ten
pennies you have 90 and at the end one
of us zero the other one 100 if we
repeat this game many times the
probability of winning or losing is
proportional to the initial stack let me
show you a simple simulation for example
let's say that you know you we would
start with like for example me as a
player I put 23 pennies and we start
playing that and what you see here is
the probability of me winning that game
after repeating that game 31 times and
if I increase the number of times that
we play that game
you see the probability of winning
approaches my initial stack so if I put
23 pennies the probability of me weaning
is 23% let's run it one more time for
example let's say that I put initially
instead of 23 pennies
I'll put 55 and we run it again so one
time I may win I mean lose as we keep
playing for example 100 times 200 times
you see the probability of me
weenie approaches my initial stack in
other word if I put down more money I
can increase the probability of winning
so it's a very simple game that we have
in you know if you talk with any gambler
they would explain you yes more money
you could increase the probability of
meaning now the same thing in collapse
models so we have two initial
probabilities we have two different you
know super positions I'm considering the
simplest case the simplest case is a
two-dimensional Hilbert space so you
have two terms initial bet is equal to
the initial probability margin of the
square of each superposition tell what
is the probability of log you know
winning or losing is proportional to the
initial stack what is the dynamic the
dynamic follows a random process it's a
100% random process what is that noise
what is the nature of that noise we
don't know it can be because of gravity
it can be a new forcing nature but it's
just a guess you know we say that let's
develop a mathematical model describing
the collapse of the wave function and if
you simulate these two strange
mathematical equation using random
processes let me just show you there
because we don't have that much time let
me just show the histogram of results so
this is the initial case at time 0 we
are 60% sure that the estate is 1 and
as time goes by you see initially there
are many possibilities because you could
get many different results but after
large enough time just increase the time
there are only two possibilities either
you win or you lose what is the
probability of meaning or losing it is
proportional to your initial bet let's
see it one more time initially so I put
down 60% one term in the quantum
superposition as the time goes by we
have a collection of different results
one time you may say let's say that it
is lucky spin up or down up or down up
or not down but if you let the collapse
mechanism to evolve for large enough
time you will get only two possibilities
the probability becomes either 1 or 0
this is the collapse of the wavefunction
after a while you are 100% sure that
this state is either up or down so here
we have a 100% random process again
what is that randomness what is the
nature of that randomness we don't know
but we somehow include that randomness
in the dynamical equation it's not a
postulate anymore we have a mathematical
equation describing that you know
dynamical equation let me show you a
different graph because of your faces I
can say that you're not very happy with
my explanation so for example let us
consider two realization log you know we
measure spin two times ok so this is the
random evolution of the probability
so we start from I set it to 0.5 1/2 1/2
chance in one run of experiments you see
we have a strange stochastic movement
but at the end we end up with zero in
the other run stochastic movement and we
ended up in one so let's run it for them
four times so for the four times two of
them we ended up being one two of them
we ended up with zero and if I keep
increasing the number of realization at
the end I can get a histogram of the
results which is what I showed you here
so you see at the end there are only two
possibilities there are two possible end
points it's either one and zero as you
can see here for the large enough time
starting from an initial value we
randomly ended up either in 1 or in 0 we
provide a dynamical description of the
collapse these models are called
collapse models sometimes they are also
called as spontaneous collapse models ok
it's at the end you know I would like to
tank couple of people who helped me
being here Stephen being you know a big
inspiration inspiration for all of our
sweet really called they helped me with
the administration Paul you know he
helped me with the Bamiyan mechanic the
Ovid he was my instructor Andre Daniela
gave the administration and feel from
Hamilton College New York City he helped
me with the collapse models and if
you're interesting the reference I would
recommend you these two books you can
download them for free from the internet
the first one is about bohmian mechanics
the second one is about collapse models
thank you
[Applause]
in Utah is random and it's not you know
the overall Hamiltonian it's not
hermitian anymore so it's like yeah you
don't need to have you know her mission
you know Hamiltonian but the price that
you have to pay for that is that change
your probability rule because the norm
of the wavefunction of decreasing time
you have to update it that's why you
know some people they call these models
as like a Bayesian approach because at
each step you have you're losing some
information therefore we have to update
the norm of the wavefunction well then
then it's no okay let me answer your
question about this so I'm not for
example let me just give you one example
you know there are some gravity models
that the how do they call it they call
it an honest on table what's the
technical term for that basically you
know for the metric of the space and
time the metric is not real anymore the
metric can be imaginary and that
imaginary term is the interaction
between gravity and one of your systems
operator that system operator is usually
mass density operator so that is the
meaning of that nonlinear term that we
added to the Hamiltonian by the way one
comment this is not the only way that
you can write down that dynamical
equation another dynamic
for the collapse model is 100% equal to
what we call as continuous measurement
continuous weak measurements so you
could if you don't like this dynamical
equation you have to add lots of other
terms to preserve the norm of the wave
function but here is the simplest form I
wonder if I answer your question we
could discuss later any other question
running out of time okay thanks a lot
for your attendance
[Applause]